thank you my talk today is about the
food purity problem which relates to
identity those food identity and our
identity and the ANC's that comes from
not knowing what you eat and therefore
who you are and how law sometimes does
and sometimes could help solve these
problems so the talk is really about
using Blackstone to assist brio Severn
answer start and this is not the
pretentious part of the talk that's not
okay gets low around a second ok now
this problem of not knowing is a problem
that has been around for ages probably
since we started eating and the law has
tried to fix it using a whole range of
mechanisms and methods weights and
measures regulating additives into food
regulating what if food can be called
what name it can be used how the food is
advertised to whom various anti-fraud
provisions and on and on and on but
today I want to focus on just one of
them one particular kind of law at issue
in one particular case pom wonderful
versus coca-cola a case from the Supreme
Court last term pom wonderful makes a
pomegranate blueberry juice drink it
contains eighty-five percent pomegranate
juice and fifteen percent blueberry
juice thus the name coca-cola makes a
drink as well it's the Minute Maid
enhanced pomegranate blueberry flavor at
one hundred percent juice blend of five
juices and that contains 99% apple juice
point three percent pomegranate juice
and point two percent blueberry juice
thus the name
in 2008 pom sued Koch alleging is
essence that name and that label is
deceptive fraudulent and tricks
consumers into thinking they are buying
and drinking a drink that contains
primarily pomegranate and blueberry
juice what coke essentially said in
defenses our name and our label comply
with all the FDA rules and regulations
and therefore that suit against us
should be precluded one cannot say well
not not say that we mislead anyone now
the technical issue in the case the
legal issue in the case is whether the
Food Drug and Cosmetic Act precludes a
Lanham Act challenge and the court said
unanimously yes without delving into it
that suit can go forward Paul may may
sue coke but a tremendous amount of the
oral argument actually focused on the
label and the name and whether it was in
fact confusing to the justices and it
was just as Kennedy went so far as to
describe it as cheating consumers which
is a bold statement so after the case
we're left with some questions new ones
when our labels misleading confusing or
fraudulent do labels actually affect
consumer beliefs do consumer beliefs
actually affect consumer behavior and
what do consumers think and believe
about the laws that govern and regulate
such labels and of course the big
question is what should law do and how
should we respond so to answer some of
these questions d van staal abohar and I
who's in the government department here
but a survey into the field last fall on
food beliefs food behavior and food
politics using his collaborative
congressional election study which he's
run for many many years it's a big study
it does a lot but we're using it for
very narrow purpose or at least for
today we're essentially going to show
respondents those two product labels let
them look at them take them away and
then ask a series of questions about the
underlying product and see what they
think
so just in passing people seem to look
at labels and they say they buy or do
not buy as a result at least sometimes
so if you show the labels and ask which
is the pomegranate juice drink more than
seventy-five percent think palm is and
only about twenty seven percent think
minute mate is these results are all
very very preliminary but it kind of
seems like they just get it to unpack
that a bit just about half correctly
concluded that palm is mostly
pomegranate juice and virtually no one
thinks that about Minute Maid then we
asked a bunch of other questions to the
effective which is organic nobody thinks
either one is which is more nutritious
very few people think Minute Maid is
more nutritious which is sweeter which
tastes better and interestingly about
how two people think there's no taste
difference at all but about that same
amount thinks palm cost more which would
you buy well nearly three-quarters is
likely to buy palm based on the labels
or so they say now i'm not a marketing
researcher i'm a lawyer and a political
scientist so what I care about what
Steve and I care about is first whether
labels generate confusion about products
and second whether that confusion
affects purchasing decisions no
confusion no legal claim no purchase no
reliance no legal claim so to answer
that question we're going to ask do
beliefs about the product do derive
beliefs from the label about the product
the quality taste and so on affect
willingness to buy these are very
preliminary results but what they
suggest is that the only thing that
matters is a belief about costs whether
you think it has more juice doesn't
matter whether you think it tastes
better doesn't matter is more nutritious
doesn't matter none of that
matters the only thing that matters is
do you think it's more expensive so if
you believe Minute Maid is cheaper then
you are thirty-three percent less likely
to purchase palms juice now it's a very
localized result we're running similar
stuff similar estimates in other areas
we're doing one with yogurt for example
and evaporated cane juice and sugar and
there it's not price of striving things
it's other beliefs so three possible
punchlines first respondents do not seem
to be especially confused by juice
labels second if they were it wouldn't
watch much matter because cost is
driving purchasing in this domain and
third Supreme Court justices seemed much
more confused by juice labels than
ordinary citizens which ought not be
shocking but which is important if we're
asking judges to administer the laws
regulating the food purity problem thank
you